all right Ellen hi Ellen where are you
from originally where did you grow up
I'm from Bangkok you're from Bangkok
yeah my family from Bangkok yeah and
tell me about your family how you grew
up you had Mom and Dad yes
how was your childhood uh I think um I'm
10 but uh Rian I want to be some
hair with lady not guy I want to uh make
uh see the movie uh with my friend lady
yeah I want to be uh I want to
make up I want to make hormone yeah I
want to be
beautiful Mall yeah how did your parents
feel about that
I didn't feel good yes I like yeah but
um my mom said while you're not paying
the guy no I don't lie yes I want to pay
with lady I want to everything same lady
yeah
and your father
babe
born why not pay uh
boxing but I don't want a scary yes but
but now in my uh she okay yeah but
everything we can make uh make uh money
working have a format here make your
face more beautiful he didn't tell me
but now you okay you're good you are
still working have the money for make
everything okay do you send money to
your family yeah you do yeah I think a
lot of the girls are doing that yeah but
up here in my family for the Prima
hotel for eating everything I pay yeah
yeah you support yourself yes
it's great
and how old are you but now 25 35 yeah
25 or 25 yes 25.
and how long have you been doing this
kind of work uh but now in the here I'm
working four months yes before I do a
working competition
before yeah you were aware caballito
vocabulation yes
yes I do a five year yeah yeah for
working calculation doing sex no so just
to show yeah but now you're having sex
for money yeah yeah how does that affect
you emotionally
are you okay with it yes yeah
it doesn't bother you it doesn't depress
you yeah
it's okay that's okay okay
and tell me about the men that are your
customers
I have a customer in some issue yes
I think Asia China yeah
you get guys from Asia Europe America
Australia too yes yeah it's interesting
do you think these guys are secretive
about their desire to be with a trans
woman
friends and family don't know but no I
think it's a secret yes
and you make good money I think some
some uh not good every day yes
tomorrow no help yes yeah but but now in
the bar now require it customer yeah no
no many many customers yeah I think High
season have many many minutes yeah
there's certain times a year but now I
think low season customer come in the
bar yeah
so you guys will be up on stage
and the guys will pick out this girl
that girl whatever girl they want yeah
you guys go where
where would you go to a hotel yeah I go
in sometime I go to my hotel sometimes I
go to chat room yes
where uh
hotel by the bar yeah okay
and how many days a week will you work
how many days uh it's one one month half
day of tea yes I uh holiday the Opti yes
but every day I working you get every
day except for three days a day yeah a
month yeah
wow that's a lot of work
do you have any regrets in your life
awesome uh We've I think now I want to
make money yes but
next time I have me money I want to uh
pay them uh
I want to be with my
buy some food yes everything I want to
uh
be more responsible with your money yeah
yeah I don't want to working here yes
for long oh you don't yes I want to make
money my money yes I want to buy some
shop uh Saron and some food yeah
everything yeah I want
so you started taking hormones yes at
what age every day yes no but when did
you start doing that uh I take hormone
I think
uh
ten I I I called a doctor if this one
okay this one okay it looked okay yes I
eat yeah I eat 10. 10 years old yeah
I take eat and
you get a shot yeah yeah and you're
still taking hormones today yeah you've
had surgeries you have surgery in here
yes in North yeah one and one yeah in
here no
are you afraid to do that or is that
something you wouldn't want to do but no
I don't want to do death you don't want
to do that yes eat next time
everything I don't want to be too lady
yes I don't want to cuss
you want the best of both worlds
yes yeah
what do you worry about what are your
fears I feel yeah you think I have it
now I didn't feel good yeah I think if
you could if I have sex with the guy I
think was okay
have you ever been in love and I must
look too full in love yeah you don't
want to fall in love Yeah I want to make
uh I think I come here to work yeah I
want to make money yes not me not meet
somebody for a boyfriend yes no and do
you have friends yes I hope you do you
that's good
and this lifestyle being trans is more
accepted in Thailand it seems maybe more
than anywhere in the world
uh yes in Thailand have many many
yes I think more
yet in Thailand how many little more
beautiful yes than anywhere in the world
yeah
and yeah I think number one how many
girls work at your club for example in
the car
I think now 40 40 yeah and everyone is
more beautiful than the next one yes
everyone more beautiful yes yeah it's
crazy
and there's many clubs like that yes
and Ellen what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
I think um
family yeah uh
family and money yes I think if
no have my knee yes
not
good yeah a lot of stress yeah
and you still have a good relationship
with your family yeah
that's great
all right Ellen thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck thank you very much thank
you